Daniel stash our author of the boy and
the boy genius and the Mogul the untold
story of television where'd you get the
idea for this well to be honest I got it
from my grandmother she had an eccentric
cousin by the name of Hugo Gernsback and
he was a big figure in the world of
science fiction in fact he's the man for
whom the Hugo Award is named and he had
a large stable of science and science
fiction magazines and in these magazines
he would often speculate as to the
coming wonders of science and some of
these forecasts such as radar and
microfilm were pretty good and others
like the Martian friendship beam were
pretty bad but one of the things that he
wrote about and wrote about often was
television and one of his enthusiastic
readers was the young Philo T Farnsworth
and who is Philo T Farnsworth Philo T
Farnsworth at the age of 14 is the man
who came up with the idea that became
electronic television technology from
the moment he got the idea it became his
life's work and on the other side of
this page where he showed the picture of
him is another gentleman who is this
that's David Sarnoff who began in the
mailroom and worked his way up to become
the chairman of RCA the Radio
Corporation of America a man who was
also deeply interested in the future of
television why do you call Philo T
Farnsworth the boy genius well the story
goes that he was 14 years old he was the
son of a Mormon farmer and he was
working in a field in Idaho sometimes
it's a hay field and he's mowing the hay
sometimes it's potatoes and he's tilling
sometimes it's beets but he was working
in a field
pushing a horse-drawn cutter back and
forth and his mind was drifting as it
often did this time on the problem of
television which was an idea he had read
about in a magazine when he got to the
end he looked back over this field and
over the neat lines that he himself had
made in
the field and it suddenly occurred to
him that it might be possible to invent
a device an extraordinary and unique
type of glass tube that would take an
image break it down into easily
transmittable lines just like the rows
in the field send them by means of
electricity and then put them back
together at the other end what year did
he think this was 1921 how old was he he
was 14 in 1921
where was radio radio was still in its
infancy that's why this idea the whole
concept of television was very very new
although a lot of people were thinking
about it a lot of people were working on
it radio itself was still in a fairly
early state in fact it had only recently
mostly during World War one progressed
beyond basic communication ship-to-shore
kinds of traffic and even the idea of
the human voice over radio was still
fairly new the Farnsworth family Philo T
Farnsworth and his family did not in
fact own a radio at the time and yet he
had this idea as it was commonly known
at the time to send pictures by means of
radio first radio station in the United
States its Berg KDKA e ka yes what year
oh gosh they were on the air very early
but as as Farnsworth was having his idea
of virtually at the same time within a
matter of months was the first time
presidential election returns had been
broadcast over the radio now the other
side of your book the mogul David
Sarnoff and say 1921 was how old and
what was he doing well Sarnoff is a
fascinating figure and because he and
Sarnoff crossed swords over the issue of
television and had a long and protracted
legal battle it's very tempting to cast
him as the villain of the piece it's
really not that simple Sarnoff in many
ways is the archetype of the American
immigrant success story he came to
America from Russia at the age of nine
in 1900 he did not speak English he sold
his language newspapers while teaching
himself English
and he got a job in the mail room of the
company that became RCA literally worked
his way up to the top from there he was
deeply interested in the development of
radio and in 1915 wrote something now
legendary called the radio music box
memo in which he speculated that it
might be a good idea if we used this
radio to bring music into American homes
this obviously turned out to be a pretty
good idea
RCA did very well with it
but even as RCA began to make millions
on radio Sarnoff already had his eye on
television which was an extension that
he considered to be inevitable what was
the Radio Corporation of America back in
those years would it do well it was it
had been called into being actually by
the United States government after World
War one they were very concerned about
keeping control of some valuable radio
patent technology that had been
developed in wartime particularly an
alternator that was allowing the human
voice to be sent further and more
clearly than ever before
just after the war of British firm
placed a large order for these
alternators and the government was a
little concerned they had spent a lot of
money protecting and developing this
technology and they were concerned about
sending it overseas the Radio
Corporation of America was called into
being to take charge of the government's
electronic patents and also at one time
those controlled by Westinghouse AT&T
and General Electric they all had a
patent pool across licensing agreement
which allowed them to use the technology
and protected it from foreign
competition for a limited time so at one
time Philo T Farnsworth the kid in the
field in Idaho was literally squaring
off against the combined might of a
General Electric and Westinghouse the
miracle of the situation is that he
succeeded to the extent that he did what
was the connection between AT&T General
Electric Radio Corporation of America
RCA and
house back in those early days well they
were competitors they were all
electronic firms they were all doing
research but by means of this patent
pool which was administered by RCA which
at that time was held separate from
these companies at the beginning RCA
didn't do anything but administer these
these patents that was Sarnoff's job
that was Wow Sarnoff became so deeply
interested in patent technology or the
control and use of these electronic
breakthroughs but they were all
competitors who by means of this
cross-licensing agreement for a brief
time had the right to use each other's
scientific advancements without paying
royalties on it this was meant to foster
greater development in fact it very
rapidly became unworkable and in short
order the government which had called it
into being in the first place moved to
break it up so how was it that you had
the red and blue networks and who owned
them well what were they the red and
blue networks were as RCA at the behest
of Sarnoff was establishing its own
radio networks they bought up a radio
network chain this was as RCA and the
royalty cross-licensing pool was
essentially breaking up there was this
huge and very complicated drawing apart
RCA was suddenly found itself in
possession of two distinct radio
networks Sarnoff was starting up NBC and
to begin with they had two different
radio networks and the story goes that
as they were tracing out how these
networks worked one that the stations
were connected with a blue pen and the
other with a rent red pen so you had NBC
radio blue NBC radio red all these years
later it creping from the RCA is owned
by the French in Danang yes like Chinese
company yes
AT&T is in a whole different business
today than was then a lot of these seeds
of what these companies became today can
be seen in this story they were all
interested in radio and for a time they
were all interested in television
including Westinghouse but by means of
the competition first the partnership
agreement then the competition and then
some quite brutal and cutthroat
competition between them they all sat
down on the roads that led them more or
less to where they are today
well what David Sarnoff think if he came
back today and saw that his network NBC
is now owned by GE I think he would
appreciate the situation because he did
at once he was at one time very close
partners with GE and there were several
people in the GE hierarchy whom he
considered business role models so I
don't think he'd have a problem with how
much the government had to do with
building of Westinghouse RCA AT&T and GE
well the government was very interested
in during wartime
but in peacetime less so in peacetime
left them to do their business but
during World War two and then again very
much so in world war in World War one
and then again in World War two the
government was deeply interested wet as
as war was declared Sarnoff sent sent a
message to the White House sent a
telegram to the White House saying RCA
stands ready we are at your disposal
mr. president who's Edward Edward
Armstrong Colonel Edwin Howard Armstrong
Edwin Edwin Howard Armstrong was a very
very important figure in Sarnoff's early
career he was a young radio pioneer and
when Sarnoff and Armstrong were both
very young men Armstrong invented
something called the called the feedback
circuit to the heterodyne circuit which
allowed radio signals to be broadcast
and received over greater distances than
ever
four and one night Sarnoff and Armstrong
were both in their early 20s went
together to a transmitter Shaq Shaq
literally a Shaq a draftee a freezing
cold thing out on the Jersey Shore
because Armstrong wanted to demonstrate
to Sarnoff who was then a general
manager at RCA well at the American
Marconi company how this thing was going
to work and years later Sarnoff wrote
whatever chill was in the air that
evening was dispelled by the thrill by
the excitement of hearing messages
pulled in from such places as Honolulu
and overseas well what Armstrong had
done was to build a better radio tube
Sarnoff signed it up right away brought
him on board got this tube for himself
and and the company Sarnoff was nothing
if not a company man Armstrong did very
very well with this he was soon a
millionaire and it pleased him to climb
up to the top of radio towers and other
equipment that that RCA owned and wave
and show his show himself to a camera to
a cameraman that he'd brought along just
to show here I'm on top of the world
literally I'm at the top of this radio
tower
he took a grand tour of Europe he said
arrived in Europe yesterday sent a
message back with the contents of the
radio corporation's safe he was having a
great time and Sarnoff was the man who
had made it happen
Sarnoff's family came to refer to
Armstrong as the coffee man because he
was always dropping over having coffee
to discuss the latest technology with
Sarnoff then one day Sarnoff said words
to the effect of you know this is great
but we still are having a lot of trouble
with static on our radio broadcasts is
there anything that can be done about it
Armstrong said yes I think there is he
withdrew into his lab he thought the
problem would take him only a few months
in fact 10 years passed and when he
emerged
he had frequency modulation or FM radio
Sarnoff had envisioned some attachment
some new tube that we would put in the
radio and the radio would be better
what Armstrong had done was create an
entirely new type of radio Armstrong
wasn't Sarnoff wasn't ready for it it
would have meant scrapping all of the
existing radios that RCA had in
production at the time starting from the
ground up at a time when he was pumping
millions and millions of dollars into
television research just couldn't do it
he and Armstrong who had been the
closest of friends now became bitter
enemies the lawyers got involved Sarnoff
testified that well yes this FM is a
wonderful thing but our scientists have
done something very similar Armstrong
was disgusted getting recognition for
his advancement and particularly scoring
off of RCA became an obsession for him
he kept at it for years and years and
years when people were urging him to
settle just to get out just cut his
losses and it finally drove him
unfortunately it drove him to suicide in
many ways the story anticipates the
Farnsworth story and the coming of
television the difference is this man
Armstrong had been Sarnoff's friend how
did Armstrong commit suicide jumped out
of a window
what year geez it was the it was the
1940s now when you talk about Philo T
Farnsworth how long did he live what
were the years that he was on this earth
warned in 1906 died in 1971 and how
about Sarnoff born in 1890 also died in
1971 Boeing same year same year later
that same year yes you go back to the
very beginning you tell a story about a
teacher by the name of Justin Tolman
Justin Coleman was a teacher at Rigby
high school in Rigby Idaho and among the
courses that he taught was senior
chemistry young Philo T Farnsworth who
had just moved
- the area was a freshman in high school
but he desperately wanted to take this
senior chemistry course every day for a
week Farnsworth camped out badgered
Justin Tolman said please let me take
the class please let me take the class
well the school year was already halfway
done
Tolman thought there was no way this kid
who was only a freshman could possibly
make up the work and keep up with the
seniors Farnsworth said please please
please and finally Solomon said well
I'll let you sit in but just keep quiet
just listen to what's going on
well Farnsworth didn't keep quiet he was
in the class it was soon evident not
only that Farnsworth knew more than any
of the kids in the class but Farnsworth
was easily on an equal footing with
Justin Tolman himself
Tolman started coming in after school
and before class to make sure that
Farnsworth was getting the extra
education that he needed and very soon
they moved well beyond the scope of any
high school chemistry class one day
Tolman was walking down the hall
and he hears Farnsworth voice coming
from a study hall and he expects to hear
Farnsworth helping his fellow students
with their chemistry assignment instead
he was expounding on Einstein's theory
of relativity which was fairly new and
certainly would not have been on the
curriculum of the Raby high school
school system at that time what was
miraculous about it
what Tolman so responded to was that
Farnsworth's fellow students were
hanging on every word there was
something about this kid when he started
talking about his ideas people listened
he just caught fire and he managed to
convey the ideas in a thrilling dynamic
and compelling way what year would that
have been
also 1921 1922 who today is known as the
father of television well it's a very
contentious issue there every country in
the world has someone that they throw up
as the father of television
and all of them have some claim or had a
hand in the development of television in
my own house there has been a debate
about who is the father of television my
two-year-old son and I were squarely
behind Philo T Farnsworth my wife who
was born and raised in Scotland will
swear up and down that it was a man
named John Logie Baird who was a very
important figure in the development of
television but what John Logie Baird and
many others around the world were
working on was a mechanical television
technology in other words your
television was going to have moving
parts inside he was going to have a
spinning metal disc called the NIP cow
disc light would shine through that disc
and perform a scanning function and it
was Farnsworth's particular genius to
realize at the age of 14 that wasn't
going to work he had to do it
electronically he would sum it up in a
single phrase later on he said for
television to work it must have no
moving parts for that reason and also
because he managed to nail down the
early crucial patents on what became the
electronic television technology that
developed it into television as we know
it today for my money the father of
television is Philo T Farnsworth but who
gets credit in this country for it often
in this country the credit goes to a
brilliant Russian scientist who worked
for RCA named dr. Vladimir Zworykin for
much of their careers Shiv oricon and
Farnsworth were in lockstep they were
working along the same lines schwöre can
who was the son of a wealthy family in
Russia had been exposed to electronic
television technology before World War
one working in the lab of a legendary
Russian physicist named Boris rosing
rosing had the idea of transmitting a
picture electronically the technology of
the day couldn't keep up with him he had
a lab that must have looked like
Frankenstein's
workroom leather straps holding up crude
glass bulbs wooden tables sparking coils
sending up electrical pulses all over
the place but rosing had this idea that
a picture could be sent from one place
to another and he imparted that idea to
his brilliant young pupil Vladimir
Zworykin the October Revolution came
along ash workin could no longer
continue with the work in Russia as he
intended to he came to the United States
and after bouncing around for several
years started to work at Westinghouse
which was one of the RCA royalty
partners in 1923 which was one year
after Farnsworth who'd had his idea of
electronic television pictures had told
his high school teacher about it
Justin Tolman Schwerin working in the
Westinghouse lab actually managed to
give his supervisors a demonstration of
a very primitive electronic television
transmission schwöre can was thrilled he
thought that this was the the greatest
thing that he'd managed to accomplish
and he was sure that his supervisors
would be carried away with enthusiasm to
get television up and running he had
managed to broadcast the faint image of
a cross at the end of a glowing glass
tube and his supervisor took a look at
it and said we have to put this guy to
work on something more useful now when
did radio back in those 20s when did he
really be I know you say they're 32
licenses issued in 21 or so note that by
the Commerce Department then there are
another six hundred women by the
following year it had it had multiplied
many times over and Farnes of Sarnoff's
vision as spelled out in the radio music
box memo almost a decade earlier came to
pass this was the
radio had made its way into the American
home and was generating huge profits for
companies like RCA General Electric you
get Farnsworth out in Idaho at the back
in those years he adds work and coming
to the United States from Russia in what
year well he came he he actually came a
couple of times but he arrived for good
in the early 1920s and you say he was
from a much more sophisticated family
than Sarna much more yes yes what kind
of a background idea
well his he grew up his family they were
Russian aristocrats work and lived in a
large stone mansion he rode horses as a
boy he was exposed to opera literature
dance he was a member of the privileged
class and of course when the October
Revolution came along that way of life
ended completely his family lost
everything when he got to West hang out
what was his physical base here in the
United States where was it Pittsburgh
and what about Sarnoff what was his
physical base well I'm sorry that time
would have been in New York and I grew
up watching a cape art television set
you're smiling because there's a reason
for that
what how did that how did he was a
senator in this town for 18 years
okay part yes well yes Kay part was a
was a company in in Fort Wayne very very
big in the manufacture of radios and
much later in the story Farnsworth and
his backers managed to get the money
together to to buy the facility they
were going to follow the RCA model and
manufacture radios sell radios to
generate income that they would use to
pour into television research and
production so the Farnsworth company
bought cape art they moved their base of
operations to Fort Wayne and things
appeared to be going very well it looked
as if this was going to work what year
would edit all of this was happening in
the late 30s and unfortunately when
world war ii came along the Farnsworth
television and radio company did a very
distinguished job of wartime production
winning several government
accommodations for their for their work
in aiding with the war effort but then
when the war effort was finally over
they had a very hard time switching
gears getting back into peacetime
production and following their original
vision of radio and television
production I'll go back to Green Street
in San Francisco and Los Angeles and all
that in a moment first how did you
personally what were you doing that got
you interested in writing a book about
this well as I told you I
my grandmother had this connection and
one day I was looking through a written
issue of Science and invention magazine
which was another Hugo Gernsback
magazine there was a contest being run
to help combat the problem of auto theft
and it was inviting readers to mail in
their ideas for an invention some
attachment that could be added to a
telenovela at that time to help prevent
theft well young Philo T Farnsworth age
14 entered the contest which was pretty
ambitious because he family certainly
didn't have a car he wouldn't have seen
many cars but he entered the contest and
wanted with something called the
magnetized anti-theft ignition lock and
he used part of the money to buy his
first pair of long pants because he was
only 14 years old it was thrilling for
me to be looking through these old
magazines and see the name PT Farnsworth
in this magazine edited by this relation
of mine as the inventor of this little
car automobile lock years earlier I had
been writing an article for Smithsonian
magazine about Hugo Gernsback who was in
the 1920s running a television station
in in New York based on this mechanical
television technology the technology
that went nowhere Gernsback is with many
things in his life sank a lot of money
into it lost at all and as I was writing
about that and describing it I was
looking around for the war
word to say well Gernsback wanted to be
a would be and i wanted to use the name
of the inventor of television i wanted
to say he wanted to be a would be edison
or would be Alexander Graham Bell I
realized I didn't know the name of the
inventor of television that's how I
started down the road and got interested
in in houthi and mater actually was
where do you live I live in Washington
DC and what would you are you writer by
profession yes I am where did you start
where'd you go to college I went to a
graduate writing workshop I went
undergraduate Northwestern and then
graduate school at Columbia high I
started out writing mystery novels and
then a few years ago I wrote a biography
of Arthur Conan Doyle discovered I liked
writing biographies very much who was
Arthur Conan Doyle Arthur Conan Doyle
the creator of Sherlock Holmes although
he would want me to tell you that he was
the writer of many many other books
besides where his home originally born
and raised in Cleveland Ohio go back to
the Greensburg connection vital T
Farnsworth read the gern's bark
magazines he did he moved to a farmhouse
where he discovered a stack of science
and science fiction magazines in the
attic and he devoured these I don't want
to claim that Hugo Gernsback my
illustrious relation was a big player in
the drama of television but he certainly
helped to put the idea into Farnsworth's
head and to a great extent probably
showed Farnsworth what not to do because
Gernsback was a big proponent of this
mechanical gears and belt drives kind of
technology what's going back
relationship to you he was my
grandmother's first cousin so you to you
and final T Farnsworth have read the
same magazines yes absolutely any many
years in a park yes yes the Naval
Academy had that what did that play in
Farnsworth his life from the moment that
Farnsworth had the idea of electronic
television transmission he was desperate
not only to put himself in a position
where he would be able to work on the
idea in other words get together lab
equipment lab for some facilities but
he's also conscious of the fact that
he was just a fourteen-year-old kid he
needed an education so in addition to
working with this justin Tolman the high
school chemistry teacher
Farnsworth read everything he could get
his hands on
Tolman recalled bringing in a book on
cathode rays Farnsworth just about wore
it out before he gave it back to him
then Farnsworth tried to get himself a
college education and unfortunately his
father passed away during these years
and Farnsworth was obliged to drop out
of college and help to support his
family he joined the Navy and went to
school in the Navy at the Naval Academy
in Annapolis hoping to further his
education and at the same time remove
some of the lessons thumb of the
financial burden on his family it didn't
work out it was never a good fit and
among the reasons that Farnsworth just
did not feel comfortable in the Navy was
he came to believe that whatever ideas
he had and developed at the time were
going to belong to the government there
were other reasons besides but he very
soon got a discharge and was on his way
back to Utah how did he get to well
first of all Wendy get married what year
that was 1926 and who did he marry
married a pem Gardner who at one time
was literally the girl next door how did
he get to San Francisco to Greene Street
well
Farnsworth had been working whatever odd
jobs he could find at one point he was
sleeping sweeping streets in Salt Lake
City
a pair of professional fundraisers came
through they were raising money for a
Community Chest fundraising campaign in
Salt Lake and they were hiring local
kids to help them map out a business
survey so they would know how to best
coordinate their efforts one of the
people who signed on was Philo and his
and his friend cliff Gardner they
started to work for these for these two
men now cliff Gardner was this brother
of his wife
we're not yet married at the time but
yes cliff Gardner was pem Gardner's
brother and at Fort time the two
families shared a duplex house they were
neighbors well one night after work at
the Community Chest campaign a man
George Everson who was one of the two
Farnsworth but one of the two
fundraisers said to Farnsworth um you're
a very bright young man
why aren't you in college and Farnsworth
explained that he'd had to drop out but
he said he had this great idea it was a
very interesting invention and almost
immediately he regretted that he had
said as much as that because Farnsworth
was very very protective of this idea of
television and lived in horror of the
day when he was going to pick up a
magazine and see that somebody else had
the same idea somebody else had been
able to patent it before him
well Everson got interested in this a
couple of nights later he took
Farnsworth out and asked to hear more
about the idea and as was always the
case when Farnsworth started talking
about the idea he suddenly became this
brilliant orator and managed to persuade
Everson in his partner Leslie Gorrell
that he had the idea this idea that was
going to take the world by storm
here's a picture anyone who's 24 years
old yep Everson said to him well I have
six thousand dollars in a special
savings account and I've been saving it
for something like this I've been
meaning to take a wild flyer on
something and this is this wild an idea
as I can possibly imagine
I'm gonna stake you to the six thousand
dollars if we lose the money
I won't squawk well Everson lost the
money they spent that much money and
much much more before any money started
coming in but he never squawked and
that's how Farnsworth God is start but
almost from the moment that Everson said
here let's go let's start working on
this idea of yours
Farnsworth realized well we're not going
to get it done in Salt Lake City Utah
let's go to California which happened to
be where Everson and greld fundraisers
were going
next on their fundraising campaign
because that was where he was going to
have access to research facilities and
equipment that he just couldn't get
otherwise so they moved first to
Hollywood and then when the money ran
out in Hollywood Everson managed to get
them backing by a group of San Francisco
bankers and they set up shop in a tiny
little lab on Green Street in San
Francisco so what year are we now and
how old is mr. Farnsworth he is barely
in his 20s when he first signed an
agreement for one of his early
agreements with Everson and some of the
backers he wasn't even legally entitled
to sign his own his own contract he had
to Everson had to be appointed
Farnsworth guardian and signed the
contract on his behalf by the time they
got to Green Street in San Francisco
where the really important early work on
television was done Farnsworth was
barely 21 there's a picture here of a
the other side of this story mister
start off where is this that is probably
a staged photograph but it is meant to
be Sarnoff at a telegraph receiving
station in John Wanamaker's department
store in New York City and supposedly
that is where Sarnoff was in April of
1912 when a dramatic message came across
the wires saying Titanic has struck
iceberg sinking fast and the story that
was told and told for years and
burnished many times over was that young
David Sarnoff sitting at this wireless
operating station became the sole point
of contact between the distressed ship
and a waiting world and for 72 hours he
stated his telegraph key with his
earphones on taking down the lists of
survivors getting information relaying
it to the press and basically serving as
the lone voice on behalf of the sinking
ship it turns out subsequently that
although yes Soren
certainly would have had a hand in
relaying the message traffic during the
Titanic disaster he was by no means the
only voice heard that night or in the
days to follow but what was unique about
Sarnoff was that he had the presence of
mind and the skill and the wit to turn
it to his own advantage use it to
further his own career by the way he's
did I know they just got in general all
the time general Sarnoff years later how
did he get become a general in World War
two Sarnoff took on the the the job he
actually went overseas without knowing
what his job was going to be and
eisenhower personally charged him with
coordinating radio communications for
the Allied invading forces on d-day it
was a job that Sarnoff did with this was
appointed Sarnoff's life when he knew
perfectly well how to give orders how to
get things done and he knew just about
all there was to know about electronic
communication he did the job he did it
very very well and he was made of
Brigadier General on behalf of his
services you make a point several times
in the book or maybe not several but a
couple of times in the book that Sarnoff
often embellished his accomplishments
well yes if Sarnoff himself was not the
man doing it certainly the RCA publicity
department knew they were on to a good
thing certainly with the Titanic story
but it has been suggested by some people
that that
Sarnoff's calling himself a general was
a bit of puffery it was not he had
served very he had made himself
available in peacetime to consult and
serve with the military he was it he had
the honorary rank of colonel when he
went into service in in World War two he
earned what he got he wore the title
general very proudly but he did earn it
so what about during right after during
World War one where he was involved in
the fourteen points in the transmission
that he took credit for I mean again you
say that he exaggerated is some of these
events he was and what about that he had
the yes he did but the there again
people around him in retrospect helped
to to burnish his achievements but
Sarnoff at one time had the had the
grace at least to be embarrassed by some
of this when he was finally appointed
the president of RCA he granted an
interview and what year would that the I
believe that was that was nineteen
thirty and a reporter from the New York
Times came and asked him and was wanted
to trot out the Titanic story again and
Sarnoff said let's put that one to bed
the Horatio Alger stuff is out of date
let's talk about the future so in later
years his he was confident enough in
what he actually had achieved that he no
longer felt he had to exaggerate what
he'd done in his early years you said
though that he had trouble inside the
RCA Corporation because he was Jewish
huge trouble why well it was not this
was a problem this was a lifelong
problem when Sarnoff wanted to become a
telegraph operator which was you know
not a fairly modest ambition but he
presented himself at a Marconi Wireless
office in in lower Manhattan wanted to
sign-on took any job he could get which
was sweeping the floors just to be
around it the other operators basically
dismissed him as [ __ ] they said you
know no place for you here
[ __ ] and although it wasn't state as
explicitly when he was trying to work
his way up the ranks at American Marconi
and subsequently RCA it was a culture
that did not have a lot of space for did
not have a lot of Jewish executives at
one point Sarnoff was literally the only
Jewish person in the executive ranks of
the Radio Corporation of America and he
found himself excluded from a lot of
meetings and
also social events whether that was
solely because of his religion or
because by his own admission he was a
pushy and aggressive young man it's hard
to say but he certainly found obstacles
in his way this is a 1933 picture of
Sarnoff and Marconi
what's the purpose of the picture
Marconi was Sarnoff's
early mentor and the story there goes
that young Sarnoff was working sweeping
the floors and trying to train as a
wireless operator at an American Marconi
station Marconi himself was visiting
America making sort of a tour of his
facilities in the United States and this
was actually the year I believe this was
actually the Year Sarnoff what the Yuri
Philo Farnsworth was born 1906 and
Marconi came visited met everyone
stepped outside to go to his next
appointment and fifteen-year-old David
Sarnoff stepped out behind him
confronted him on the sidewalk sat hello
you're my hero
my name is David Sarnoff told him his
whole life story which included
emigrating to the United States buying a
newsstand and and really struggling to
help put food on his family's table and
Marconi really responded to this and
Sarnoff became Marconi's errand boy
essentially during his visits to New
York and did whatever Marconi wanted
which in the early days included taking
flowers to Marconi's various girlfriends
around the city which was the job that
Sarnoff apparently handled with with
great dispatch but over time with
Marconi's personal recommendations
Sarnoff was able to get his foot in the
door and start climbing the ladder and
it was a relationship that the two of
them fostered for years and years and
years American Marconi became GE after
World War one when it was no longer
deemed expedient to have foreign control
of American companies particularly
American companies dealing with this
kind of sensitive
ecology American Marconi was sold off
and and no longer owned by the parent
corporation British Marconi - you say
that was brought about by the government
yes it was then jump to 1939 you say
that Philo T Farnsworth invented
television but what's this
that is the 1939 World's Fair where RCA
in general and David Sarnoff in
particular intended to raise the curtain
on television now at that point they
were at the end of a long and protracted
legal battle with Philo T Farnsworth and
also that same year 1939 an agreement
was hammered out whereby RCA was going
to have the right to use Farnsworth's
patents technology and what you have to
understand about that is that in
Sarnoff's 50-year career at RCA the
company had never ever paid to use a
patent owned by an outside inventor
Sarnoff liked to say we don't pay
royalties we collect royalties he had
his own inventors he had his own patents
whatever patents he couldn't buy he
would find a way to get around the only
exception in 50 years was Farnsworth and
the legend goes that this was so
devastating to the RCA lawyer that as he
put his name to the agreement with
Farnsworth lawyer there were tears in
his eyes but nevertheless 1939 it looked
as if an agreement was coming with
Farnsworth and Sarnoff ahead of the rest
of the industry wanted to announce
television was here RCA was going to
bring it to you and he seized on the
1939 World's Fair as the stage on which
to do it RCA had a great big exhibition
hall Sarnoff himself took the stage
there were RCA
microphones in a big banner and he said
now we add radio site to sound and a
television supposedly was on the way
then the following week you could buy a
television in a New York store at prices
ranging from nearly $400 to $1,000 the
price turned out to be way way too steep
what would that be Monet's money you
know I figured it out once and it was
something on the order of seven thousand
dollars so it's sort of a
high-definition television set sir
yeah and but you know that's a lot of
money high-definition television at
least you know it's going to work this
nobody'd seen it before nobody knew
whether it was going to work or not and
for a time television came to be known
as Sarnoff's folly because as he liked
to say he'd spent fifty million dollars
on television before he ever saw a dime
well in 1939 he hadn't even seen the
dime yet the televisions were coming off
the assembly line in Camden New Jersey
nobody was buying a made banner see made
by RCA Sarnoff cut the prices nobody was
buying them then the year was 1939
America entered World War two and
television went into mothballs for the
duration of the war
by the way did they actually pay money
to foreign jurors for the patent yes
they did
yes they did how much money well yes
it's hard to put an exact figure on it
but there was a payment of about a
million dollars and an agreement to pay
royalties to use Farnsworth technology
in RCA television sets it is difficult
to say how much that would have amounted
to but since America entered World War
two almost immediately thereafter it
didn't amount to anything because
Farnsworth early patents had been nailed
down in the early 1930s and a patent of
this type only had a useful life of
seventeen years when television finally
got off the ground
in 1946 1947 these important early
patents of Farnsworth's were coming up
for
expiration he never benefited to the
extent that he should have
well you Green Street in San Francisco
for how long
Green Street in San Francisco for from
about 1926
to the early 1930s 1930 1931 then he
signed an agreement with Phil Coe a
company that a lot of people assume was
named for him but what actually was the
philadelphia storage battery company he
was there for a few years in
Philadelphia that didn't work out
Farnsworth went out on his own for a few
years and ended up in Fort Wayne how
long do you live in Fort Wayne
well the Farnsworth family had a retreat
in Maine and Farnsworth where in Maine
by the way oh gosh it was I'm sorry I'm
blanking it was a very isolated spot and
Farnsworth loved it and he had worked
himself so hard in this relentless
pursuit of television that his health
was beginning to suffer and in Maine he
could regroup he could get his balance
back he built himself a nice laboratory
he's still young though still a very
young man he was born in 1906 1906 in
the 1930s this is a man still in his
early 30s but he liked to say of one of
his early companies that his small size
enabled him to operate like a speedboat
among their juggernauts but he added a
speedboat eventually runs out of gas and
unfortunately that is what happened not
only to foreign to his company but to
Farnsworth himself he used himself too
hard he never took a break he just
couldn't shut it off he prided himself
as a young man he could go to bed
thinking about a problem and he would
wake up in the middle of the night
Eureka I have the answer he would go
back to work but that took a toll it
took a terrible toll very early on and
all the way by the way
were there other systems being used and
whether programs being transmitted and
oh yes permits under way
well the yes
were here in Washington DC there was a
man named Charles Francis Jenkins he had
a line of televisions again using the
mechanical television technology this
spinning disk inside the television was
he programming it he was because in
these very early days basically if you
bought a television from say Charles
Francis Jenkins you were only going to
get a Charles Francis Jenkins
transmission and it was pretty crude
stuff and there were other others across
the United States and in Britain John
Logie Baird the Scottish television
pioneer was also doing the same thing he
was manufacturing these mechanical
television sets and providing the
programming you'd be lucky if you got
two hours a day but very early on in
1920s that a man named - Ernst Alexander
s'en who actually worked at RCA but was
still a big proponent of the mechanical
way of doing things managed to broadcast
a melodrama called the Queen's messenger
and it employed three cameras one for
eat the face of each of the two actors
involved and one for hands hands were
shown holding a gun holding a flower
taking gloves on and often things like
that I mean very crude stuff but if you
had a television set you'd be able to
get it in the late 1920s this this
relation of mine Hugo Gernsback was
printing in one of his magazines
instructions so that you could build
your own at home you could build a
television following his directions with
lenses mirrors and a spinning disc and
he Gernsback was going to send you
television pictures
chances are the the picture was going to
be no bigger than a postage stamp it
would flicker and in the case of the
Gernsback televisions you couldn't get
sound and television at the same time so
you'd get like a snatch of violin music
and then a picture of the violinist
later so in the end though when
television finally began being used and
in what year would you put you say 46 47
46 47 one television as we know
today transmitting we're from what city
well from New York but there were there
were broadcast networks so it very
quickly spread across the United States
was Sarnoff the first one to actually be
in business there are many who would
disagree but yes on a large scale
yes Sarnoff and RCA were the first would
you have had television the way we know
it without Farnsworth
I mean is he still got a piece of this
action and yes yes he does is his family
still get money no they are not as I
said earlier the patents were expiring
very early on but from the earliest days
the technology that went into the
television camera to particularly was a
blending of Farnsworth best work with
the best work of Vladimir Zworykin who
was the man who was making it work at
RCA there's a picture you have here at
the front of the thirteenth chapter in
1957 well that would it be would have
been 51 yeah yeah that is Philo T
Farnsworth and we're only television of
parents on the game show I've got a
secret he traveled to New York he signed
in as as dr. X so just in case someone
recognized his name and he had been
written about a fair amount and he was
very relaxed and comfortable on
television but this is the only time he
ever appeared the panelists formed the
idea that he was some kind of medical
doctor and that he invent he had done
some sort of medical breakthrough and at
one point he was asked doctor X this
device of yours is it painful
when used foreign source didn't skip a
beat he said yes sometimes it's most
painful audience got it you know gave
him a big laugh but the panelists were
unable to guess which meant that
Farnsworth won the top prize which was
$80 and a carton of cigarettes first
commercial on NBC Bulova why a watch
just a watch face ticking around 60
seconds Bulova watt beloved wife four
dollars mmm four dollars what in the end
he did you say both Sarnoff and
Farah died in 71 were they friends were
they acquaintances well no they were not
but unlike many of the other business
adversaries that Sarnoff had come across
in the course of his long career he
always had a grudging respect for
Farnsworth some of that was legally
motivated because it was clear at one
stage that Sarnoff was was going to have
to come to an accommodation with forints
Worth and in public addresses and things
Sarnoff began to say outside of the
Radio Corporation of America no one has
done more than this splendid young man
Philo T Farnsworth but no they could not
be said to be friends so how did
Farnsworth die and in what circumstances
how much money did he have and what or
was he he was unfortunately not in good
health and his doctors recognizing that
he was having a hard time relaxing
prescribed things that made him
dramatically worse he began to have a
problem with alcohol and he was
prescribed some chloral hydrate which
just made things very much work very
much worse another doctor told him gee
maybe a finger habit will help to soothe
your nerves why don't you take up
smoking so suddenly Farnsworth not only
drinks but he also smokes addictively
another prescribe some painkillers
because he was beginning to have stomach
problems which eventually led to very
serious ulcers for a time he had a had a
problem with with painkillers but he
never stopped working and he never lost
the conviction that he was going to be
able to help humanity with one of his
ideas and if it wasn't going to be
television in later life he fastened
onto the idea of finding a peaceful
application for atomic energy he
envisioned a great grapefruit-sized
power pack that would help to power a
house for its entire lifetime
he imagined that entire cities could be
cheaply cleanly and ikan
fueled by atomic energy and it is the
measure of the high regard with which he
was held in the scientific community
that these ideas were taken very
seriously
unfortunately as with television nobody
ever put up quite enough money and
Farnsworth himself once again had to
find the money to try and make it work
he wound up cashing in his own life
insurance policy mortgaging his own
house but he wanted to make this thing
happen
and he ducked any family yes but as with
my Conan Doyle book as it's sometimes
better to go in without taking sides and
I since I did want to tell the two sides
of the story I tried to try to keep a
professional distance where where is
Farnsworth buried Oh Farnsworth is
buried in not Fort Wayne
and what about Sarnoff and how did he
die so sorry off was older than
Farnsworth obviously yeah he's buried in
New York and he had only very recently
given up the controls of of RCA he was
too ill to carry on he was largely
confined to his home on the on the Upper
West Side of Manhattan and passed away
at home having learned only a short time
before that he had in fact been asked to
give up his board position our guest has
been Daniel stash our here is what the
cover of the book looks like the boy
genius which was Philo T Farnsworth and
the mogul who was David Sarnoff thank
you very much for thank you